das sind wirklich krasse zahlen derzeit
leben mehr als siebeneinhalb milliarden
menschen auf der erde und 80 millionen
menschen kommen pro jahr dazu das sind
so viele wie die einwohner deutschlands
und die rasant wachsende weltbevölkerung
ist ein problem denn schließlich gibt es
nur eine erde und zwar mit begrenzten
ressourcen was sind die konsequenzen was
können wir tun das jetzt alles bei
klickst du uns in fischen
[Musik]
vielen dank denen sie und herzlich
willkommen und vielen dank an euch für
den coolen themenvorschlag auf whatsapp
das ist wirklich wichtiges thema aktuell
leben fünfmal mehr menschen auf der erde
als im jahr 1900 und dieser trend ist
nicht zu stoppen fakt ist oder das
zeigen zahlen
ein rückgang der kinderzahl kann vor
allem durch die wirtschaftliche
entwicklung eines landes gelingt
investitionen in bildung
arbeitsplatzschaffung sexualaufklärung
gesundheitsversorgung und
gleichberechtigung zwischen mann und
frau tun ihr übriges
wenn frauen wirklich die
entscheidungsfreiheit haben wie viele
kinder sie bekommen wollen sinkt die
geburtenrate eine bessere
gesundheitsversorgung für alle sorgt für
eine höhere lebenserwartung und mehr
menschen sind länger erwerbstätig das
ist gut für die wirtschaft und der staat
kann mit den höheren einnahmen den
lebensstandard der bevölkerung
verbessern
das ganze wird oft als demografische
dividende bezeichnet und es gibt
tatsächlich auch beispiele aus der
praxis die zeigen dass das funktionieren
kann thailand und südkorea
beispielsweise in südkorea hat die
regierung eine langfristig vernünftige
familien planungs und gesundheitspolitik
betrieben so dass in den 70er jahren die
geburtenrate massiv zurückgegangen ist
zudem wurden die südkoreanischen frauen
in den arbeitsmarkt integriert was die
wirtschaft des landes enorm verbessert
wir leben einfach in komplett
veränderten zeiten und wir als
zivilisation müssen darauf reagieren
durch die medizin bessere versorgung und
so weiter überleben immer mehr menschen
die alterspyramide die haben wir quasi
abgeschafft früher starben die menschen
einfach in einer fast gesetzmäßigen
regelmäßigkeit durch krankheiten unfälle
behinderung und so weiter und so fort
das ist heute einfach nicht mehr der
fall zudem lag das durchschnittsalter
dadurch aus wie niedriger alleine
dadurch dass wir länger leben gibt es
viel mehr menschen auf der erde und wir
müssen als zivilisation sowie südkorea
darauf reagieren und von südkorea könnte
sich afrika viel abschauen
denn das alles könnte auch dort gelingen
doch bisher sind die prognosen für
afrika ganz andere die bevölkerung dort
wird sich in den nächsten 30 jahren
verdoppeln
mehr als 40 prozent der menschen dort
sind jünger als 15 jahre
zunächst müsste ist die politik dort
schaffen die geburtenrate zu denken
senken zudem müsste ihnen die junge
generation in afrika investiert werden
schulunterricht haben dort die wenigsten
kinder die meisten frauen haben keine
ausbildung und so gibt es für sie keine
alternative zu ihrer rolle als mutter
und hausfrau
das haben auch die vereinten nationen
erkannt und haben diesen punkt nämlich
die gleichberechtigung zwischen den
geschlechtern als eigenes ziel benannt
wenn zu dem auch die gesundheitsdienste
verbessert werden merken die familien
schnell dass viel mehr kinder überleben
als sie dachten denn das ist doch der
punkt es werden so viele kinder geworden
weil die eltern immer noch davon ausgeht
dass so viele von ihnen starben
schätzungen zufolge dauert es dann wenn
sie verstehen dass mehr überleben etwa
zehn jahre bis die menschen von sich aus
eine kleinere familiengröße anstrengen
und so gibt es schätzungen nach denen
das bevölkerungswachstum und nur ein
drittel zurückgehen würde
wenn paare und vor allem frauen das
recht hätten frei über ihre
familienplanung zu entscheiden
die überbevölkerung bringt große
probleme mit sich in ländern wie afrika
bis asien und dem nahen osten sind die
menschen schon jetzt lange nicht mehr
ausreichend mit sauberem wasser nahrung
infrastruktur und arbeitsplätzen
versorgen wenn noch mehr menschen unter
diesen schlimmen bedingungen leben
müssen weil auch die zahl der sozialen
und politischen konflikte steigen eine
weitere folge der überbevölkerung ist
migration der natürlich machen sich
menschen die in solchen chaotischen
zuständen leben müssen auf in andere
regionen in denen sie sich eine
perspektive auf die große frage die in
diesem zusammenhang immer wieder
auftaucht wann haben wir das limit der
erde erreicht ein wenig erinnert das
ganze jahr an bakterienkolonien und ihre
exponentiell
wachsende produktion population in der
petrischale sie werden immer größer bis
sie durch die neue lösung begrenzt
werden dann sterben die bakterien ab und
die populationen bricht zusammen wann
also sind die ressourcen der erde für
uns menschen aufgebraucht und droht uns
dann dasselbe schicksal
auch wenn die studie des
österreichischen physiker heinz von
foerster nicht ganz ernst gemeint war
hat er den tag des untergangs auf den 13
november 2026 prognostiziert seine
studie basierte auf den daten von 960
und war ein mathematisch angelegt doch
was dazwischen kam war beispielsweise
die sogenannte grüne revolution und
weiterer technologischer fortschritt der
jederzeit möglich ist die
nahrungsproduktion wurde durch neue
effiziente getreide züchtung und den
einsatz von mineraldünger vervielfältigt
der hunger der erde wurde damit nur
eingedämmt aber nicht besiegt es ist ein
regionales und kein globales problem und
so etwas macht es schwierig die frage zu
beantworten wann das limit der erde wohl
erreicht sein wird in deutschland werden
mittlerweile ebenfalls immer mehr
stimmen laut dass man auf eigene kinder
verzichten sollte stichwort
nachhaltigkeit das motto also nur der
mensch der nicht geboren wird ist
nachhaltig doch andererseits ist leben
wert von und zwar jedes einzelne an
wirklich schwieriger konflikt und so
steht einfach außer frage dass alles
dafür getan werden muss dass alle
menschen die geboren wurden auch gut
leben können und dafür müssen die
ressourcen der erde vor allem erst
einmal gerecht verteilt werden wenn ihr
kein video dazu und zu allen anderen
themen verpassen wollen dann endet mich
bei whatsapp dann um geht ihr die etwas
unzuverlässige hamburgs hier auf youtube
und ihr verpasst kein video
denn über whatsapp erfahrt ihr von mir
persönlich von jedem upload und zwar
noch vor allen anderen täglich und
garantiert einfach hier draufklicken und
am besten auch meinen schwestern kanal
klicks um social media abonnieren
da gibt es das neueste aus der social
media welt dafür hier kriegen aber nicht
die
die glocke vergessen die geht es weiter
mit dafür auch draufklicken aliens und
klimawandel
die zerstörung der erde steht bevor bis
dann bleibt